during the summer of 1776 political
leaders from across the American
colonies gathered in Philadelphia to
debate what to do next about the growing
list of wrongs done upon them by the
British crown on King George the third
had completely abolished colonial
legislatures and at station two standing
army in the American colonies Britain's
own territory during peacetime
now our founding fathers ultimately
decided to make one of the boldest and
most important decisions in all of human
history to break away from the British
crown and to establish a government
based upon the idea the government
should protect its citizens rights not
have an executive violate them and we in
2015 faced an equally serious threat of
excessive executive power in November of
2014 President Obama announced that he
would suspend a deportation for millions
of illegal immigrants living in the
United States and so today we must
confront the limits of executive
privilege in order to prevent further
tyranny from taking root in the United
States we must first examine our
founders understanding of tyranny before
then taking a close look at the
stipulations they then placed in our
founding documents in order to prevent
tyranny and we'll then delve into the
progressive rejection of our founders
limits on the executive and finally
discuss how education is the best way to
restore a constitutional executive now
me was to reaffirm our belief in our
founding principles for as Edmund Burke
said Kings will be tyrants from policy
when subjects are rebels from principle
now our founders experienced with
executive tyranny greatly informed their
thinking about the role of the executive
and government now our founders become
to believe that the executive is
something that is necessary but also
something that must be tightly
controlled even before the Revolution
colonists greatly resisted executive
overreach in 1761 Massachusetts resident
James Otis delivered a speech entitled
the rights of British America asserted
and proved in which he stated an
original supreme absolute earthly
sovereign must exist in and preside over
every human society it is originally and
ultimately in the people now here otis
encapsulate what our founders
come to think about the executive there
must be an executive in society order to
enforce laws and protect rights but this
executive must always be beholden to the
people and if an executive does not
enforce law and protect rights well then
something must be done
and on this note our Declaration of
Independence clearly lists the wrongs
done upon the American colonists by the
British crown in the years preceding the
Revolution and King George the third had
either weakened or completely dissolved
colonial legislatures stations standing
army in the American colonies during
peacetime courted these soldiers in
private American homes forced taxes on
the American colonists without their
consent completely abolished the English
law system and created an arbitrary
government here our founders saw the
other and darker side of the executive
if an executive stops enforcing laws and
protecting rights well then he is no
longer an executive he is a tyrant and
from this experience with the executive
our founders crafted a constitution to
melt the necessity for an executive with
strict limitations upon his power our
Constitution does create an executive
office the president who has
specifically enumerated powers that
allowed him to enforce laws conduct
Foreign Affairs act as
commander-in-chief of the military and
the like but this president's powers are
checked by the powers of both
legislative and judicial branches and
Federalist 51 James Madison writes that
the interior structure of government
must be arranged so that its constituent
parts keep each other in their proper
places
now what James Madison is telling us
here is that the more moving pieces of
government has whether its local
government versus national government
house versus Senate Congress versus the
president versus the courts the less
likely that any one of them or all of
them combined will be able to oppress
and this I found a solution to executive
tyranny wasn't simply the best solution
for their time it was the best solution
for all time because our founders
understood that power will always eat
away at morality and self-control near
the turn of the last century a group of
thinkers emerged to it rear a's the
specter of executive tyranny and
the American progressive movement
completely rejected both the founders
and Constitution's limits on the
executive one of progressivism most
prominent voices Woodrow Wilson called
in a 1912 speech entitled what is
progress for a more modern
interpretation of the Constitution
Wilson stated all progressives asked for
is to interpret the Constitution
according to the Darwinian principle now
here Wilson sees social structures as
constantly evolving which makes our
Constitution a relic of a bygone era
that only hampers good government in the
modern era because modern government
must be unleashed so that it can
confront the great social ills of our
time now Wilson further compares
governments to living creatures in the
same speech he states no living creature
could have its organs offset against
each other and live now government is a
body of men with a common task and
purpose and there can be no successful
government without the intimate
cooperation of the organs I here Wilson
completely undermines the Constitution's
ideas of checks and balances in a
balance of power vital safeguards
against unlimited government now Wilson
sets a dangerous precedent for both his
intellectual and political successors as
he completely undermines both the
founders and Constitution's limits on
the executive and now we find ourselves
with a progressive thinker in our white
house who brings about the great
constitutional crisis of our time
unlimited executive power our President
Obama unites the desire for progressive
government with social action our
president has made many unilateral
executive actions during his time in
office for example President Obama
unilaterally raised the minimum wage for
federally contracted workers to $10.10
an hour he's made over 28 unilateral
changes to Obamacare all after the law
was passed and even a Supreme Court
blocked the president's power grabs when
they unanimously ruled in June 2014 at
the president's recess appointments the
National Labor Relations Board were
unconstitutional but all of these events
came before what was perhaps the most
egregious disregard for the president's
enumerated powers on November 20th 2014
President Obama and now
that he would suspend a deportation for
up to five million illegal immigrants
who have been in the United States for
five years now no matter the sorta
stipulations the president has created
new laws ex Nilo disregarded old laws
and completely shredded the legislative
process in fact our president has taken
executive power so far that he threatens
to become the king that our founders
feared and so we must ask ourselves how
can we stop this from happening again
well now that we understand our founders
understanding of tyranny and what modern
thinkers and politicians have done to
undermine it we can discuss what we can
do to help restore a constitutional
executive and we might ask ourselves
what can we possibly do I mean we're not
politicians what influence do we have
but there is something that we can do
education in Abraham Lincoln's Lyceum
address he addresses the possibility of
a tyrant arising in the United States
and in order to prevent this Lincoln
rights or require the people to be
attached to one another and to laws and
government and to be generally
intelligent to successfully frustrate
his designs
now we must therefore attach ourselves
to laws and government by educating
ourselves about them we need citizens
from all walks of life to be thoroughly
imbued in the history and significance
of our founding documents Hillsdale
College where we are gathered here today
plays an important role in that
education the college is dedicated
educating not simply those students who
are here on campus but also concerned
citizens everywhere who care about
limited and constitutional government
and an educated populace can then
intelligently wield their right to vote
to support candidates for political
office from the State Capitol to Capitol
Hill that support our Constitution and
this group of intelligent and motivated
voters is our last best hope against the
forces of modern tyranny for us Ronald
Reagan said freedom is never more than a
generation away from extinction
it must be fought for preserved and
passed on now just as our founding
fathers gathered in Philadelphia in 1776
to debate what to do next about a tyrant
so we must be equally concerned about
the future of the form of government our
founders left behind for us so today we
examined the great constitutional crisis
of our time in unlimited executive
and in order to do this we examine our
founders understanding of tyranny took a
look at the stipulations they placed in
our founding documents in order to
prevent tyranny
we'd ovince the progressive rejection of
our founding principles and finally so
how education is the best way to restore
a constitutional executive now if we
take up this challenge to educate
ourselves about laws and government then
we can save our descendants from
despotism and leave behind for then a
form of government that is free limited
and constitutional thank you